hello and welcome to the lobby game
spots weekly hangout every tuesday at
2pm pacific right here on gamespot.com
or twitch.tv forward slash game spot if
you're watching live special thanks all
y'all listen to this on your podcast
machines make sure you rate subscribe do
all that stuff i don't know what's going
on i'm sitting here on the lobby set uh
the this week week of all weeks the 20th
anniversary of gamespot.com sitting
across the table from two
people who are way cleverer than me at
this
mr peter brown reviews editor hi and
you're the person you are cosplaying as
presumably
kevin
kevin
hello previous reviews editor here at
gamespot.com uh you were just passing by
the office today i was actually yeah
well when i was little i was literally
out walking and i sent a text to peter
saying oh i sent a text to peter
uh
saying hey i'm
so so i got a new job but i'm gonna be
leaving at some point like to a far away
place leaving leaving yeah leaving
leaving and i wanted to make sure to you
know things are really busy and hectic
and i wanted to stop by and just make
sure that i got a chance to see game
spot peeps before
i suddenly just disappeared from the
continent
and uh peter's like hey while you're
here why don't you do this thing and so
i did the thing and then you do my job
for me for like two hours sure and then
danny's danny's like hey can you stick
around for the lobby and it's like i'm
like i got anything else to do yeah the
minute you leave here there's gonna be
someone else roping you into something
which is fine which is fine i love being
back this is actually my first time
since you've changed floors right but
i've that i've i mean i've seen y'all
but i haven't been in in the building
building yeah
since you moved july of last year yeah
july of last year so but
i guess it's perfect to hear because we
wanted to have a section about
gamespot's 20th birthday and you you've
been here
longer than than most of us here i think
maybe i was here
almost nine nine years all right um so
before we sort of get to the the past
past i want to talk a little bit about
what you've been doing what have you
been doing
since we've seen you last because you've
got a whole new adventure coming up in
the next couple of months but i already
had adventures before that yeah so i
when i first uh i mean when i left
gamespot i i went to try on worlds um i
was first working there on a game called
devilian which i hope everybody plays
uh
but uh we localized davilian we did not
develop the villain we um we localized
davilian at try on and so most of my job
was spent uh writing writing writing
writing lots and lots of words right and
uh at that point when when that sort of
finished um when that part of the
localization finished um i moved over to
the atlas reactor team as a designer and
so i did a lot of stuff with
on atlas reactor which is awesome and
you should all play it when it's when
it's widely available and hopefully the
people that played the free steam
weekend i'm sorry i'm shouldn't be
pimping this no [ __ ] away
i mean presumably we're not paying you
for coming on the lobby no i'm not being
paid for being here kidding
uh
so so i did that and then uh
and then since then i've been working
with a
with an indie team cleaver soft and we
are making uh a platformer with dragons
called earth night which is also really
great um but i have nothing more that i
can really share about that since we
don't have a release date we don't have
like there's a it's a
sony exclusive i can say that much
because we already know that it's a you
know ps4
vita um what are you doing on that one
i'm a designer design so like so how
does that because i know obviously you
were like prolific writer here yeah like
peter can attest to the fact that when
you're in your work position you spend a
lot of the time smashing on keyboards so
presumably it was like oh that's a good
fit you're going somewhere else to write
about games how did the shift into
design happen and what like what element
of design are you working on because i
i'm completely ignorant of how this
stuff works well i mean there's a lot of
stuff that goes into design and so so
i'll give you an example on atlas
reactor when i was with with trying
working on alice reactors uh that
involved level design so if you liked
the second map i designed the second
half
so uh that was so that was great on
house reactor but i also did things like
writing character scripts and uh
voice over sessions and oh wow doing
things dealing with the
progression scheme things dealing with
monetization that was apparently all
thrown out the window since the game
went to pay to pay to play rather than
free to play and things like that so
that's what i that's sort of a jack of
all trades right um on alice reactor
devillion was basically writing writing
writing writing
for cleaversoft most of what i'm doing
is also level design which is a little
bit different it's a 2d game
a 2d platformer so i spent a lot of days
doing things like what some people do
with like
super mario maker is that i'm just
basically taking all of our assets and
tools and trying to keep them
consistently fresh and interesting and
doing
new things with with the platforming is
sort of what i'm what i'm doing right
now after nine years of writing about
games what's it like not nine months out
of us doing all this crazy stuff well i
mean i miss you guys but luckily i've
had the chance to do some stuff here and
there and i'm even working on some stuff
for peter now um sort of maybe my final
hurrah i don't know like i thought
journey would be the you know journey on
ps4 would be the last uh the last thing
i ever wrote for gamespot and that that
got proven wrong did you follow that up
with what was that so uh a bombshell was
my shift it was my first review after
that and as you probably know i i
disliked bombshell with a great passion
yes so but then i mean i've i've gotten
them to play like i got to review hyper
light drifters so i went straight from a
two to one to a nine well there was
something in between i forget what it
was
i never know there was something
in between i don't know but uh working
on um
witcher 3 blood and wine yeah for you
guys as well as uh
the odin sphere hd
you reviewed witcher 3 as well i did
review from the original witcher 3 it
was my personal game of the
times before you year yeah you know me
i mean in the end i guess i gave out
three while i was a kid metal gear for
yourself
which are three and uh journey journey
on ps4 which in my mind is probably one
of the most perfect games i mean if you
think of a 10 as perfect which i don't
but if you do think of a 10 as perfect i
think that's one of the most deserving
games i can think of to be given a 10.
our game of the year in 2012 and also
mary's favorite game of the past
20 years as in our one of our many
features were put together this week on
gamespot celebrating 20 years um
of of the website 20 years a long long
time we'll talk about what you what's
coming up on your next adventure yeah in
a little bit but uh let's let's get a
little bit
wide-eyed nostalgic a little bit here uh
peter when did you like when did you
join gamespot how because for me you've
been here for like forever you're like
part of them as a staff member you mean
yeah yeah when did you first start
writing a bag
well for gamespot uh that was
october 2011 maybe november
um i was working as a cook in texas
trying to get freelance writing as much
as possible and uh i got a job opened up
for a
job earning strategy guides game spot uh
i lied about my address
i reached into my my well of uh
references which was uh curtis said who
used to work here who i worked with at
1up.com back in the day
and
spent all my money flying out here and
um and have since learned that i
probably didn't have to lie about living
in california
but uh she said like number 10 second
street san francisco i had a friend who
was like okay man yeah you can use my
address but i mean you know bottom line
was i had lived here before texas and i
could have come back so i was well
prepared for the journey but not
prepared for uh i think how big of an
impact gamespot has had on my life right
um i worked at a place called oneup.com
which i'm sure a lot of people remember
and just down the street here yeah yeah
literally like two blocks away and that
was a really special time for me but
nothing has really left its mark like
gamespot has on me and i uh you know i
people you know they talk about a work
life balance and even like my close
friends try to you know persuade me to
maybe work less but i think they don't
understand that like
this is kind of like it it's threaded
into me now like gamespot is my life for
better
i don't want to say for worse i mean
sometimes it's a job and jobs are
stressful but
gamespot has been a positive force in my
life yeah yeah you feel like you've sort
of got a lot of responsibility when you
get your your ticket on the plane uh
kevin
you came from a sort of a similar place
to me but long long before me in fact
when you got hired it made me feel a lot
you know sort of hopeful for from my
chances you came from the community i
did i uh i was a moderator
for years
um on the gamespot forums and at some
point i started
just writing for well i was always
writing reader reviews and things like
that too but i was a moderator on the
forums for a while and then um i started
writing for game spy another place you
might have heard about yeah uh along
with one
but uh i was i wasn't employed by game
spy but i was i was a freelance free
game spy in addition to doing writing
for uh
a site that that now doesn't exist in
the form that it used to
um
for free just just for the fun of it and
i got a call out of the blue from jody
robinson who was in community at the
time and there was this position for a
tournament coordinator
and i was the first person they thought
of so it's not like i had applied for a
position i just got a call
um and they said hey why don't you come
out and interview for this position i
was like okay
and so the company put me on a plane and
brought me from
from where i was living at the time i
was living in maryland and working in
virginia and they flew me out
uh for a job interview that didn't feel
like a job interview at all it felt like
gamespot trying to sell itself to me
which was the strangest thing
um so i said okay i'll i'll completely
change my life and i'll move to i'll
move to california yeah and i left life
behind and so that's what i did and then
nine years later i was still doing it
and
you know i loved it i mean
you know like peter said it's it's a job
it's not as you know but but it's weird
when sort of life and leisure intertwine
like work and leisure intertwines in the
way that they can do in the games
industry
um
but it was time you know sometimes you
just have all this creativity and you
realize it's time to use it in a new way
all right so that's that's kind of what
i did it wasn't really it wasn't because
i wanted to escape game spot or anything
i mean nine years is time to you know i
wanted to i wanted to do new things but
i wanted them to be with games because i
love games so much and and i wanted to
put my money where my mouth was in in in
a way and say hey okay i can write about
them but let's let's see what happens
when i make them now i mean i feel like
jumping into the sort of you know into
the unknown is something that if you
were to ask you know there's only three
of us here if you'd ask anyone who's
outside you know working on production
or out on the floor or even all the
people who've left you know in in the
past coming years uh that's like
sort of the ubiquitous tale as like most
of the people who work for
this site and even kind of when i think
about ign down the road it's it tends to
be people who have traveled far and sort
of left everything and left all their
their their family and people they knew
before for like a brand new life and i
mean
it never kind of feels like
you had any other choice to do it
because trying to break into this
industry is like
such a difficult like so much of it
involves
time and place even even after you get
in man yeah you take an opportunity
where you can there's there's no
you know when it when it comes up you do
it because
you love it and because there's no
guarantee that anything else is is going
to come up and that happens on both
sides of things i mean certainly in game
development right
my time at trion was cut short for you
know by by just the kinds of things that
happen in in the business of making
games in the business of reporting on
games it's just that cycle and so you
take what you can when you can get it if
it's the right thing i mean there's
certain things that i obviously i'm not
going to do but you know when you know
when these when these opportunities came
up it's like yeah you got to do it
otherwise i'm just going to be saying
for the rest of the time what would have
happened if i hadn't if i if only i had
done it i wonder what life would be well
now i get to know and as it turns out
it's pretty great so
um we got a bunch of lovely uh comments
in here team toaster saying kevin's
assassin's creed one review was the
thing that made me follow gamespot back
in 2007. wow nobody ever said that about
that review people
that was one of my so you know there's a
long history of course of reviewers
getting hatred from you know whatever
yeah
who knew
but i mean the earliest game spot that
really started happening was with the
command and conquer three review which
which
well because it wasn't that long after
um supreme commander had come out right
um and i scored come in and conquer
three higher than jason ocampo had
scored
uh speak about her two supreme commander
one
yeah and so that was kind of the first
time i ever had people kind of whining
at me for something um but assassin's
creed is also another interesting one
because of course i reviewed both that
in the original mass effect and i
actually gave assassin's creed a higher
score than i did the original mass
effect um and that that haunted me for
for quite a while obviously i stand by
that and i still stand by assassin's
creed one as still the the assassin's
creediest of assassins creed in the
sense that it's the game when you're
most like an assassin
in that series so so yeah i i totally
still love assassin's creed one to this
day when you think about the sort of i
guess before you worked here what can
you remember any like
reviewers or
shows or like any things you ever sort
of
wrote or what or sorry read or watched
on gamespot before that made you
interested to work on the site
gamespot was always kind of present um
as i like trolled the internet looking
for things that magazines didn't provide
to me right like back during the days of
dial-up screenshots yeah um but i think
different from you guys i wasn't really
like a hardcore fan of the site right
when i showed up here um
for whatever for every reason i don't
know it's not like i didn't like the
content you know but i i'm i'm so
focused i think on
at least in the past anyways it's
different now but in the past i was so
focused on like hyper like japanese
console games and stuff like that and
gamespot always had the
it seemed to have the pc audience more
in mind yeah sort of more mature games
um and that was all well and good but it
wasn't what i was looking for
um but then when i when i got here i was
just like blown away by
the character of everyone on the team
their skill and how they made me think
about games differently i mean i thought
i knew things about games then but i
it's incredible the amount i've learned
since i began here
um
yeah
was it you that sent me an email
um maybe was somebody sent me an email
not so long ago
about you know about uh reviews and
things on the site that i thought were
interesting from the last 20 years
because of course the anniversary was
coming up and it might have been rob
yeah maybe it was rob um and and i got
and it was interesting like when i once
i started going through all the things
that made me love game spot before i'd
even come here
i was really surprised like not
surprised i guess but i was just like oh
my god i can't forget about this but i
also can't forget about this and for me
greg casavan was always of course the
the the big gun
uh when it came to sort of who i looked
up to at gamespot because it was
thoughtful but it was also funny and
nerdy and and just sort of
you know i i felt a connection with greg
in terms of what we liked and things
like that and you know maybe and i think
it was things like
neverwinter nights
his review of that there was andrew
parks hysterical uh gods and generals
video review which is still my favorite
video review a visit that exists
um from gamespot uh
i mean everybody looks to big rigs and
alex review is a classic but i i really
do think andrew parks gods and generals
reviews uh video reviews you know is
kind of stands on its own but i mean
pretty much anything greg did but
there's also
a review that i don't think anybody even
knows on the site that was one of the
biggest for me and that's ryan davis's
project snow blind review
um that was i mean notwithstanding the
fact that i had a huge crush on ryan
davis for the longest time
uh there there was all there was just
you know that review was also one of my
and still is one of my favorites on
gamespot and i don't think anybody even
really knows that review it it almost
seems like a lot of great words spent on
a game that nobody thinks about anymore
but
um
so much i mean all those it was the
people that i loved and and they seemed
to be writing
to to tastes that i had that was always
that was the reason number one why i
wanted to be here i never actually
thought you know you you think you know
i'm thinking in 2002 well wouldn't it be
neat if i worked at gamespot you know
you don't think that four years later
that that thing is actually going to be
happening yeah do you remember like
three four years ago you cracked some
joked me in the hallway about me having
your job one day
i thought that was the most absurd
notion no i don't remember that
you probably wouldn't but at the time i
was like
that's crazy
but you know i said that
i'm sorry i didn't mean to to overwhelm
the conversation no worries no i mean
not like yeah like i remember being back
home and watching on the spot in ireland
like seven years ago and to think that
like so much of your life gets impacted
by
you know joining a place like this it's
it's really crazy we're very very lucky
uh speaking of your sort of your uh
admiration for greg casavin you have had
a similar sort of post life post review
uh in a sense yeah journalist life um
let's talk a bit about what you're doing
next because that's a bit oh yeah that's
a bit of a jump it is it is a bit of a
jump so uh it's it's been a little tough
to make happen because
well i mean you'll see why in a second
um so i'm i'm joining larry in studios
um the the people that make divinity
original sin the entire divinity series
so if you know if you know divine
divinity in all games that came came
after that then you know larry and
studios so that for me it's a dream come
true in a lot of ways number one is
because dfinity original sin was my game
of the year yeah remember um
so
you know and it's it's like
again let's like the other thing where
it's like you don't actually think you
know it's not like when that happens
like oh maybe someday i'll get to
actually work with with larry in studio
you know you don't think that's gonna
happen but uh yeah it looks like in
about
as soon as i can get all the the rest of
the paperwork in order yeah cause
they're not in sacramento are they kevin
no they're in belgium
so
so in about a month i'll be moving to
ghent belgium which which will be really
awesome and it's very frightening but
i'm really excited to see what comes
next and they've been really good to me
uh
uh
the whole the whole company just seems
really great and they've been
really patient seeing if the paperwork
happens it's really hard as it happens
to you know you got to get your work
papers you can't just i can't just move
to another country and say amen
which is what they it's how they say
hello when belgium actually says hello
yes no but you can't yeah you can't just
show up and decide you're going to work
there's a there's a lot of government
rigmarole and
somebody on twitter said to me that uh
you know this is just to prepare me for
how much uh europeans love red tape oh
yeah for sure so uh it looks like i'll
be having some
some red tape
in the future with your palm freight
yeah yeah um which is weird because now
i'm moving to a land most well-known for
for
chocolate
waffles and beer now now that i'm now
that i'm vegetarian and i've lost all
this waste
and not eating things like that so we'll
see what happens although to be fair and
beer
and and it's funny because i've never
really been a drinker so it's it's
interesting though belgium uh ghent
specifically has uh every thursday is
veg is vegetables day reality
um so everybody on thursdays that lives
in ghent is uh is uh inspired to eat
their vegetables it's gonna be all weird
vegetables they're not used to like
brussels sprouts and turnips though well
brussels is there so it makes sense that
they would be in the brussels jeez danny
know your know your globe
but it'll be interesting and you know
learning flemish um yeah basically funny
dutch
uh so that that'll be fun um so there's
a lot of stuff to get ready for i'm
really excited and i'm also terrified um
utterly utterly terrified i think i get
what everybody would get to it's like a
huge change what if something happens
what if i'm not good at it what if you
know you you know what if what if i have
a heart attack before i go and nothing
ever and and i don't get to see it or
get to do it or or something like that
what if the plane crashes out of the sky
and i don't get to have this amazing
opportunity you know it's like that's
but that's the way i think that's just
my br how weird my brain is so
but yeah that's that's kind of what's
happening next and uh you know how long
that lasts i don't know that's the fun
thing about
the fun and terrific another terrifying
thing about games making it's about life
about life for sure because you don't
know what happens i mean i i i had no
idea how long i'd be at triumph but i
was hoping it would be more than it was
and then
again you know
this is a really financially strange
industry
so you don't know what's going to happen
which is why i'm trying to connect
myself also with as many any projects
cite any projects as i can because
they're on you know you get to you get
to wear a lot of hats too with those
kinds of things and you get to be part
of you know you get to be a bigger part
of the decision-making process and
things like that with smaller projects
you know not everybody gets to be like
part of this core indie team that just
go you know you not everybody gets to be
double fine and just kind of move from
one project to the next and just kind of
be this awesome
unit you know there's a lot more flux
typically
so anyway yeah that's what's coming next
so i'm excited um
so dvd original sin two ten yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah now collusion you
can say it to me i'm not on the reviews
team yeah
if i only review it if it's a formula
one game i'm i'm kidding of course i
mean one one incredible secret that
nobody talks about in the games industry
is that uh game developers know pretty
much how good their game is before
before anybody else gets their hands on
it so
um yeah and typically not the case every
time but typically i mean that's that's
just the way it is so you know i i you
know hope you all like atlas reactor too
i already know how much you like
pavilions i hope to like every game i
mean isn't that what we all hope for
yeah i mean you want every game to be
awesome that's what i'm saying yeah
that's the thing yeah about every game i
make to be awesome we've had a bunch of
really awesome ones this year already
and here's to some more it's been a
fantastic year it has already i think
it's doom and uncharted and overwatch
today uh kevin thank you so much for
coming in yeah really appreciate it uh
nice to have a lovely chat about uh the
history of i guess the sort of the the
past the present and the future i mean
that's what websites are right it's just
a bunch of people who are contributing
in the best way they can and contribute
they leave and next people come in and
the wheel keeps on spinning
so yeah thank you so much appreciate it
peter brown hi we're gonna ask you to
stick around
because you got fallout kevin you don't
know much about fallout at all of you
you never played you never played for
says the man who reviewed fallout three
fallout new thing have you had a chance
to be followed before considering you're
working so much i did not i i got very
close but i did not beat fallout 4. but
honestly part of that has to do with the
fact that i don't like fallout 4.
um
it's too much of a shooter i felt like a
lot of choice has been taken away from
me um and i have lots of niggles i can't
stand the way con the dialogue and
conversation systems work in fallout 4
for example so i have a lot of problems
with the fallout 4 but honestly i can go
back and play new vegas with mods
anytime i want and so you know i get
that i i can i can still have the
fallout experience that i love and
that's that's you know go back and play
fallout 2 or i can play wasteland 2
which is which is also fantastic so lots
of lots of things to do if one game
doesn't meet your needs there are
thousands of us yeah there are a bunch
of them uh mr handler you want to come
in here and relieve mr van ort are you
heading out right now then i don't know
what do you want me to do i don't know
if you're still here in 30 minutes we'll
i'll see you and and hang out with
people outside all right cool and i
guess rob can take my place for now he's
much better looking anyway uh the chat
all saying lots of uh lots of uh good
lucks and thanks for popping in thanks
and seriously i i guess before i get up
i'm sorry rob no no you're prettier than
i am but sometimes age before beauty
and uh but seriously you know as much as
to be i want to be fair to everybody out
there because i mentioned something
about you know you know reviewers get
hate a little while ago but i also want
to make sure that it's you know without
you i don't i wouldn't get to be
get to do what i had gotten to do
and uh
you know as much as it can be hard to
like deal with kind of deluge of people
that don't like you and say nasty things
to you um i did it day in day out
because i loved it and because i hoped
that maybe somewhere out there you know
i could help other people love it too in
a in a different way or to start to
appreciate games in a new way in a in a
thoughtful way and and uh over the years
i got a chance to to grow in that
respect because i was surrounded by
writers that i admired and people that
made me look at games in different ways
than i had before and i hope that i got
the chance to do that for some people
and and whether or not you you liked
what i had to say or not i hope that
whoever was out there knew that i did it
with as much love and passion and and
certainly
honesty and it's easy to always you know
nowadays it's easy to just oh you know
journalists suck and you know buy us and
and so forth and so on but you know we
we do it because we love the games and
because we really do have something to
say and hope that what we have to say
can have have meaning for somebody
and uh hopefully and all of that
somebody out there a few people out
there found found something in that you
gave it to me for sure i hope so you
definitely did and uh i you know that's
that's all i really want in the end is
just for people to keep looking at games
in in new ways and and to keep looking
at that art form and saying
you know this is some of the things
we've done and we've got a lot more
awesome things to do yeah for sure
here's to the future yeah thanks kevin
rob all right
on that note come on kevin getting in
here and making us all well off right in
front of the camera don't worry about it
you've earned us you can do what you can
do you want that speech absolutely
seriously my first day i'm sorry so my
first day on the set
i did [ __ ] like this all the time
all right should we talk about some
video games
yeah i guess yeah i have this titled as
is far harbor worth buying i'm a massive
fallout 4 fan i love playing it you
enjoy fallout 4. i do you gave it a 9
out of 10. i did it yeah rob handlery
you also enjoyed fallout 4. is far
harbor worth picking up peter first
for 25
i would have a very hard time
recommending it really yeah
i mean it goes deeper than should you
buy it or not because it depends on what
you want out of it all right so what are
we talking about in terms of let's get
down to the boring digits what are we
talking with game length game winning
add-on length dlc length i'd say it's
it's fair to estimate between you know
like let's say an average like 15 hours
if you're really trying to go out there
and like do a bunch of stuff right if
you're only interested in sort of the
main path the story
six hours
i'd say around there
um so it depends on what you want if you
want to seek out a lot of crazy mods
like rob you know yeah that's where
you're gonna buy a lot of your time all
right let's speak to some of that stuff
then right off the bat so how did you
enjoy far harbor what did you think of
it what was sort of the most of the
activities you were doing with your time
with the game yeah i mean i was making
features so i was kind of playing in the
sense of uh new weapons what are the new
weapons new gear i was kind of investing
in
a little bit more of the side quests and
exploration there's a lot of cool areas
to you know every building has a story
which is still the same case very
fallout ish but uh mainly the weapons
weapons are for the most part
fun
uh you got some cool new ones like a
harpoon gun yeah which uh was surprising
you could uh if you you know if you
impaled someone in the head i made a
feature where i did not expect it but
sure enough the head ripped off and
impaled into a tree
uh that was a fun surprise you know you
get some other um types of weapons um
but
yeah
having not actually finished the main
storyline this is where i think peter
was gonna get at was you know what do
you what do you like out of fallout do
you like exploring
and just soaking in
having
no real drive to maybe finish the main
storyline but like kind of just
exploring and you know there's so many
new buildings and such
in that case i'd say go for it but uh
the
main storyline
i got kind of burnt out on myself and
peter you had some problems with the
story as well didn't really tickle your
interest i mean like fall out of
if anything fallout's main campaigns
have always been a sort of a bit of a
sore spot even fallout 4's main campaign
is kind of fine it's the side quest
stuff is usually a bit better um so the
main sort of
thread in this one the main quest uh
you've got some issues with it without
getting into too much into spoilery
stuff sure i mean
let me at least say that like for
fallout 4's you know main campaign like
the primary storyline i appreciated that
like i appreciated the things that it
did and specifically the the time and
space it gave me to sort of
figure out how i fit into that and how i
want to uh influence it right um
far harbor
it's it's this very quick procession of
okay here's one group okay now here's
another group and here's the third group
and here's a problem and uh what do you
think what are you gonna do about it
what's your choice huh hey hey hey
and you know it even raises some
philosophical questions about
i i don't want to say anything but it
raises some philosophical questions
that
seem completely unearned uh because one
they're illogical and two the sort of
drama behind it kind of comes out of
nowhere and
i felt like my character like the
character i'm role playing was
ill-equipped to address something like
that in in an instant and yet here i was
basically able to make a decision yay or
nay that would influence like my
character's psyche completely right and
i just didn't feel like far harbor sort
of earned
the the weight that it was
it was offering me in terms of you know
uh drama and was that because you were
sort of being introduced to all these
characters so quickly and then
i'm okay with being introduced to them
fast that's fine but it's sort of the
actions they take in the way that they
impart their identity and the role that
they play onto you
uh it just felt like it was this sort of
immediate delivery of
it wasn't just who they are but
what they stand for and how do you feel
about that yeah
uh without giving you the time to really
feel it out you know i mean granted you
could go on side quests and prolong your
decision
but the fact is is that these questions
are raised very soon after you meet
these characters and it's just kind of
like well i didn't even have a chance to
like
take a second i mean you can tell them
hold on i'll think about it i'll be back
in a second right but these questions
should come later and uh and that's
unfortunate but you know to rob's point
like i i do appreciate the world like
it's more
more fallouts combat more fallouts
exploration is it a big area
because i'm all about that exploration
so that's interesting i wouldn't call it
huge like a lot of people i'm seeing
right about the game are referring to it
as this like massive thing like for dlc
maybe but it's kind of odd because that
you know that's what my impression was i
mean one of the main selling points was
what like bethesda's biggest add-on to
date right landmass
and i found i found it pretty easy to to
get around and you're
you're exploring things pretty quickly
um
but
one of my frustrations as well and this
is even ties into like the fog nature of
the island right
everything has fog
and it kind of
gets old at least for me pretty quick
like i bought this new graphics card
[ __ ] exactly and we'll get into how
it performs i guess a little bit later
but
you know for an area that i'd like to
hit a you know say i climb the top of
the highest peak
uh
fog
you know like i'd like to see some
something different i like that that was
cool about fallout 4 right like you get
these areas like here's this now i'm
even closer here's you know here's the
blimp of the brotherhood so the fog is
just kind of ubiquitous
it just gets pretty stale for me at
least um and if you want to get into the
performance yeah talk about some of that
because before we actually got i mean we
had preview code which had some some
interesting frame rate issues did that
stuff ever get resolved or is guess what
no it didn't okay
i'd say a little bit all right uh you're
full of [ __ ]
no i wouldn't say that i just i know
well i i mean i i played the the preview
build wherever we had yeah and it was
unplayable it was like really bad right
it was a single digit frame ten frames
right yeah maybe like this so this was
um
p this is for ps4 okay uh so this was
again this is strictly in the fog and
then when you got combat combat going on
good luck like it's
so atrocious your uh footage i was
looking at looks
playable but i would not be comfortable
saying it's like did you play on ps4 or
pc ps4 and i watched him play a little
bit on pc which he'll explain also kind
of exhibited some optimization problems
nowhere near as bad i mean i'd say like
i have uh i played even on a
670 at home and then a 970 here in the
office and
i've played this game before it should
be a solid 60 i've optimized it prior
and it would get
downwards to about 30 maybe 45 uh
strictly in the fog
and combat situations in that fog it's
weird because i remember there were some
people who were having ps4 problems at
the original remember jeff
yeah giant bomb was having some problems
with the ps4 version of fallout 4 proper
and like none of us did at all yeah i
remember the lobby episode we talked
about yeah actually yeah so it was
interesting but it's funny that i get
once again i mean fallout 3 historically
had problems on playstation as well
but yeah it seems to be sort of a
recurring problem with those guys yeah
and it's really just because of the fog
i mean it's the vol
it's either physics based or volumetric
you know fog in it whatever it is it's
causing that game to have to crunch more
numbers and it's it's style choice right
i mean the fog could be there it doesn't
have to be so
strong yeah but or even like
you know i mean i'm not a developer but
i think it'd be aesthetically cooler if
it
came out only at night right or like
just had these had these moments because
i mean i'm a big fan of that you know
like the
ideas of like oh
you know you thought you thought it was
worse now here comes the fog like in
waves you know like just to kind of keep
a nice different pace you know i don't
know but it's just kind of old it's just
constant and it's just kind of flat yeah
all right so we've talked a lot about
the problems that are with this thing
i'm assuming it's not a complete train
wreck no is it fun like i mean the
combat and fallout is pretty great like
i happily spent hundreds of hours
playing this game already because it's
just fun to shoot stuff and exploring so
i guess are you enjoying that aspect of
far harbor yeah dude new environments
new monsters new weapons i mean
considering i like the combat all of
that sort of just gives me more to chew
on new things to see it was great like i
like that part a lot more about yourself
yeah oh there are a couple new monsters
that were really surprising and how
awesome they were like these uh these
mutant salamanders called gulpers like
they are
just the [ __ ] worst dude you see him
from afar and they come at you and they
do this like snake slide so you're like
trying to get your crosshair on these
dudes yeah and that's like oh yeah
that's what you want but uh they're
super fun yeah tons of new uh creatures
and um
again the weapon i came i did a piece
and then stumbled across this weapon
that someone said in the comments oh you
didn't you didn't find the striker right
there's a bowling alley on in the aisle
or on the island and in it it's it's
again this is like where fallout for me
is the best like my favorite memories
are taken away from where someone you
know got the freedom to make their own
story in one environment you know
without anything else yeah so it's a
story
if i spoil it but it's pretty cool
in the end of it
you get a bowling ball launcher okay and
have at it it's super fun so you're just
firing you know bowling balls at like
dudes heads which you had done with the
junk junk jet junk chat with because you
could put voting balls in that as well
does the character say strike
no
even better though
no no even better though this is gutter
no once you get the kill it's uh the
sound effect of pins knocking down
it's like there was like one guy here
that
is there a speaker on this thing
but it's fun yeah all right so i kind of
feel like this would have been the
perfect bit of dlc to play if you've
gotten the like cheap version of the
season pass or something like it kind of
totally not to bring the whole money
into you know whether it's worth it
debate all over again but well sometimes
it is i mean this has been how many
months now since we played fallout you
know half a year at least six months
yeah not counting automatron stuff right
but yeah like it's been a long time for
some people so throwing another 25 bucks
at something is
i think a reasonable thing to consider
yeah all right when will the review be
live on gamespot working on the video
review right now i'll be live tonight
okay cool so it may already be up by the
time you watch this if you're watching
this on demand you're watching this live
and make sure to come back to
gamespot.com later this evening for that
review thank you so much gentlemen i'm
out of here you are out of here you're
both out of here i'm sick
let's get some uh let's get some new
folks in here
the the white guy mario go round
keeps on rotating
no just just for one tay you we've got
you don't worry
we're here to talk about
i mean it's surprising we've gone 40
minutes on
today's show without talking about this
game to be confident i think we should
be commended really i think we've done a
fantastic thing so i think so i think
we've done it i was playing a little bit
while you were doing lobby how were you
really yeah i was playing but this
morning all right let's jump into it
overwatch it's out
it's finally out you can go but it is a
game you can purchase if you want you
can buy some weird loot crates we bought
40 worth of loot crates didn't really
get all that much out of it to be
completely honest but that's a
discussion for another day uh mike
mccarty you're reviewing this for
gamespot um it's almost hilarious that
you're reviewing this game considering
we've been playing it for what seems
like an eternity yeah four months when
will the review be hitting game spot uh
6 a.m
pacific tomorrow okay yeah um
it's it's pretty much scored and
everything the review's ready we just
wanted to do our due diligence and wait
like 48 hours the servers are completely
fine just like if something happens to
go wrong in the next 12 hours then we
didn't want to risk that okay it's ready
to go up so there's a review and
progress up on the site at the moment if
you want to check it out if you have any
questions for mike please put them in
the twitch chat i am keeping an eye on
it before we get him involved eric hey
what's up how you doing my friend doing
all right i always feel like you're a
very good barometer for online uh
shooters whether or not they're going to
be popular or not because like for
instance there are games that i enjoy
online shooter wise such as overwatch or
games that i do not enjoy but end up
being very popular such as uh destiny
and the division yes thank you fair
enough um so i guess what's your sort of
take on this we went back we went to
blizzcon two years ago
we were very i mean the first preview
games whatever we did this was the two
of us waxing lyrical about how much fun
this game seemed to be already uh now to
run the opposite side of the launch what
do you think about overwatch what do you
think about it sort of lasting appeal
it's mainstream appeal how popular you
think it's going to be
uh definitely still fun even though like
you said we've been playing for a while
uh i
now that you asked me that question
though it's kind of interesting because
i'm kind of wondering like
will this at all have a titanfall effect
right at all you know like
could you see yourself playing for four
weeks just like yeah overwatch four and
then like four weeks later you're just
like
yeah overwatch you know what i mean i'm
not sure like i think i think i'm still
having fun everyone like my battle net
list is full of people playing this game
so
it's it's been fortunate for me to be
able to play with other people which is
one of the
the big reasons you you play a online
shooter multiplayer online shooters
because you have your friends playing so
if it has that call of duty effect i
could see myself playing for a while
because you know
you hop on for an hour or so like you're
playing i'm playing it's like hey let's
squad up or something let's play then i
could see myself playing for a while but
you know there are
uh only so many modes right now you know
challenge or the uh the kind of the
league type more hardcore things got out
yet so
it'll be interesting to see kind of like
the landscape in a month but i think
definitely for now it's a fun game again
40 at least on pc non-origin i think is
fair you know the loot box thing is kind
of weird but you know it is what it is
yeah they'll always get those whales uh
mike how you feeling about it i like it
a lot so we put up the review in
progress like you said we had already
played like 60 70 hours of the game or
something up there uh it was pretty
definitive review and progress i love
the game i think it's a fantastic game
uh
the best part about it is you can play
like this amount of time and still be
finding new things with new characters
that work well on this map or against
that character or with this character
there's all these layers that keep
revealing themselves the more you play
with the game and that's why it's so
great and despite how like flashy it is
it seems simple at first there's only
three game well four game modes three
you know regular ones then a hybrid 12
maps
21 characters it doesn't you know like
essentially 21 classes really
complicated classes yeah um but then the
more you play it the more you realize
how much there is beneath the surface
and that's why like i keep playing it's
just to see like how i can master this
character learn this one you know figure
out how i could have done something
better in hindsight with this character
it's just it's a really engaging
learning process and still hasn't
stopped i mean it's funny when we talk
about the amount of content that's in
this game that always comes up in terms
of review scores or in terms of asking
price and whatnot and i think about some
of the games that like some of the
first-person shooters specifically that
i
would consider like in my top five of
all time or whatever like i'm a huge fps
fan fans fps is definitely my favorite
genre and to be completely honest i've
been burnt out very much so on fps games
for about five years i feel like they
haven't really done much at all i feel
like the last great fps was half-life
too and we've sort of been you know
there's been some interesting ones like
titanfall i definitely liked um but we
haven't had any like great new games
except team fortress 2 is probably not
another good shot
and the thing that sort of like strikes
me about when i think about those games
is like when i think about all the time
i spend playing counter-strike and that
was like three maps
like there were more maps but nobody
played it nobody you know aztec came up
every once in a while but it was like
you were playing dust and you know
office got rolled in and dust too and
then some lunatic on you know
counter-strike source would play
compound and then you know but that was
fine and there was enough like the
moment-to-moment action was not was
enough fun in its own right to get you
to keep playing and to keep playing and
to keep playing and i've not felt that
with an fps game probably since then
since like 2004 with with counter-strike
source and and beyond and this game just
has it in spades like it has that and it
also has these 21 characters which
just like you said it keeps unraveling
itself like i'm characters that i think
i know how to use i keep learning new
things about them all the time uh but
yeah i guess eric you're right there are
you know some games that they come and
go like your titanfall which is a
wonderful game but you know petered out
and then you've got games like you know
the last big game that sort of rocked
this office in rocket league which was a
game that we just enjoyed it so much and
it was enough people playing it that we
kept going back to it and i guess
probably another way in which that got
longevity was because they just kept
releasing content for it uh what do you
think about that in relation to the sort
of longevity of overwatch
uh
again like
the only thing we know for sure is that
there's gonna be kind of like a harder
like a more hardcore type tier of
gameplay right like for your you know
esports type people or whoever
and so
i think that the novelty and the fun of
it's always going to keep people like us
playing i i feel that way because it's
like rocket league
we have a lot of people to play with
yeah but i don't know what it's going to
be like again in like a couple months
like from now because
will all the characters be enough for
you you know are these enough game modes
do you still have enough friends playing
are the is the drop off of friends
playing stopping you from playing
because like most people don't like solo
queueing i don't like solo queuing so
that was kind of like the one hurdle i
was afraid of with this game which is
like if they all stop playing if you
guys all stop playing i probably won't
play
but um i still i still think it's it's
gonna do
pretty well for now because there's like
i don't i'm trying to think of like big
games coming out like soon and i don't
think i yeah i have any too many coming
out so definitely gonna be playing for a
while and i still have fun and like i
said it's got that call of duty effect
for me where it's like okay i know i'm
going to hop on and play yeah so like i
mean if there's anyone's good at keeping
people playing a game for a long time as
well blizzard are pretty good at it yeah
some questions coming in philander is
talking about his fear with multiplayer
games um when i guess you're stuck
playing with people you don't know what
do you think about that mike when you're
playing this game when you're reviewing
it are you constantly going into groups
of other people do you play with pubs
and you sort of consider that as part of
the process
yeah i mean this game's really good uh
of whether you're playing with people
you know or whether you don't know and
in the sense that if you're playing with
people you know the communication helps
a lot right if you're you know you're
zarya say i've got my gravidon surge alt
ready and your friend who's hans will be
like oh let's do it like launch a dragon
arrow into it name escapes me um
sorry the uh
but it's also good about like there's so
many accessible ways to play it right
you can play as a mercy if you're not
like a typical shooter and you don't
want to like be berated by these
hardcore players right you play as uh
you know winston who doesn't require a
ton of accuracy you can just go right
into the fray you can play as you know
if you're if you played a lot of
titanfall and like that you'll probably
acclimate to diva or someone it's
there's a lot of entry points in this
game but then it's really good at
communicating
how to play it in like really good like
visually audio cues like you hear it's
high noon you want to get out of there
like you start to realize it after a
while after you die three times or after
you hear that if this game's really good
at communicating its ideas in a way that
you don't that you can play it as from a
hardcore perspective but you can also
come into it from an accessible
standpoint that doesn't really sacrifice
any substance in the process i will like
just to slightly counter that or just to
play devil's aggregate a little bit um
i'm waiting for more of the people to
start playing of course and two to kind
of stop playing it from a death match
type of perspective because there's a
lot of people not doing what they're
supposed to do you know getting on the
payload getting to the checkpoint you
know defending these checkpoints like
like you said even when we were playing
together we ran off one time and we
almost lost because of that right and
that's really frustrating or
a good example was i was playing with
chris and maybe a few others in the
office and we happened to have a
widowmaker that was on offense but it
wasn't necessarily a good map
necessarily for her for her she was
killing people and he was like oh yeah i
got 20 limbs we're like well we're
you're not helping capture the point
yeah and you're not helping us hold the
point so maybe you want to switch he's
like no but i got 20 eliminations i'm
not changing and it's like well okay
i mean so that's the fear that's like
the slight feeling i guess the fear i
have is that and i think this is
probably why they're going to launch
their you know ranking
sort of skirmish or mode or whatever
they call it again
in the beta right like because
eventually you're going to have this
situation which is definitely what
happened in counter-strike in other
games where there is this massive like
skill floor where you've got or probably
watermark is better to describe where
you've got a lot of people who are very
very good at the game it's like when you
try to play gears of war after a month
it's like a nightmare because everyone
knows how to do the road you run around
the corner and to use the shotgun and
all that and this is a game like many of
those are games that requires them to
really split apart those two groups to
allow like the rating groups in wow to
have their fun and then to allow the
adventurers who just want to walk around
the album first for 40 levels do their
own little thing as well so i think
that's probably what i'm what i'm
interested in but it is crazy that we're
talking about this game in those like
terms we're not saying is this a game is
it going to sell we're talking about is
this going to be the next biggest first
person shooter for like two years yeah
like that's i feel like where this
exists to address your point today i
completely agree because there are
people today like even i still sometimes
maybe not so much anymore but there were
times when i caught myself like you were
just saying it's like oh this isn't team
deathmatch what am i doing like i'm
playing zarya i shouldn't be worrying
about just like chasing this trait sir
endlessly um it's i think the game
itself the way it communicates those
things like you know the post-match
voting period where you kind of like
recognize your teammates who
this lucio healed this percentage of the
team's total damage this mercy to the
same this reinhardt absorbed this much
of the shield that way i think that's a
way to encourage people like you can
there's not one way to play this game
but you should be focused on filling
roles and also like i think it does a
good job of uh
in when you're building your team it
says there's no tank here it was like a
red bar like yeah
i think people who are willing to pay
attention
to this game and kind of suspend their
habits they'll find something they
really like here that really encourages
teamwork and encourages this nuanced
approach like as a team against like
your opponent but yeah
it will get frustrating after a while if
competitive mode doesn't come along soon
enough and we're still playing with
these people who are widowmaker every
time on offense just worrying about you
know
eliminations and whatnot i mean i think
it says a lot that you know people are
already kind of figuring it out and the
game's been out of day and like looking
at the twitch chat here like it's
literally just a group of people saying
oh but this character does this and this
character does this and this like
they've managed to make a game where
there's 21 different like individual
classes basically where people like
they're getting it like they're asking
people to be smart it's not like call of
duty it's not like what we've been fed
for so long like even games like halo
where it's just like just shoot the dude
like they're actually asking you to use
your goddamn brain for once and that's i
think why i want this game to be
successful because it's a thinking
person's shooter which
for years we were being told was not the
way to get the mainstream audience to
play it yeah a shooter doesn't always
have to be just about shooting like
we've kind of been conditioned to
believe lately you know that's why like
i like old school battlefield games
that's why i'm excited for battlefield
one it's about this substance that you
find like these things that you talk
about after be like remember when you
know rob and i flew that biplane and i
was hosing a few like them in a dog
fight and this game hasn't even come out
yet i'm just it's a tangent but but
overwatch you know like it's it's good
about you know junkrat's really good
about closing off these choke points and
kind of trapping people when they come
around you know winston can just disrupt
this objective by jumping in with this
all and raging and he might get down but
he's gonna buy time for zarya to
literally just stand next to this
payload so we have a few extra time
minutes for everybody else to get up to
the checkpoint i think the way that the
game communicates to you visually and in
its user interface with the voting
period and the actual team building and
the audio cues and the way it actually
punishes you for not playing the
character well right not like uh not
like a you're you're casual player what
are you doing
it's more of a it's more of kind of
nudging you in the right direction and i
think it assumes you're intelligent
which is pretty special for a shooter
for games in general it's pretty special
which is sad to say um but i i think
i think this game communicates itself
well enough that more and more people
will quickly get on board with what it's
trying to do it's gonna be very
interesting to have a chat about this
six months from now very much looking
forward to it uh mike when is the review
going up again uh six a.m pacific
tomorrow uh which is the 25th
6th 26th i have no idea it'll be yeah
this video may be live by then or not
who knows
but yeah you can check out our review on
gamespot.com right then all right we're
not done talking about overwatch i want
to have a little chin wag mash i said
that because you're here
wait what was the other one donkey
monkeys oh okay donkey here's a
first-person shooter donkey's years
which is yeah because like that doesn't
make it any better because i plural i
thought somebody said donkey ears
donkey's ears and for some reason my
brain couldn't parse that it was
donkey's ears not donkeys ears uh yeah
donkey's yours that's i didn't find
crazy people
the holocron days what's that called
synecdy is that the place
the movie is like cynic doc
well the real town in uh new york is
schenectady schenectady and the movie is
called synecdotee is it well it's a play
on cynic dosh or something so that's the
thing i used to when i lived in ireland
i don't have a clue about this place in
new york so i called it sign a douche
new york
i had it on dvd that would be a really
great sign to see on the highway you
might as well pull off the air from a
gas station
we won't get murdered or anything
anyway yeah the chat's full up in there
chalk and cheese donkey's ears yeah
all the all the idioms i've had to leave
behind or apparently haven't anyway
let's not talk about endearing
specifically
yeah we're gonna have a nice little
chinwag right now um let's have a little
chat i mean we've been putting up all
these overwatch hero videos for the past
week or so shout out to everyone who's
been helping put that together uh chris
waters mary cash jean-luc in the back
for helping me edit them as well good
good times uh but let's talk about i
guess our favorite characters between
the three of us what are the characters
that have spoken to us maybe a character
that you didn't really like originally
but you sort of grown to love uh mike
maherty you first of all who do you want
to get the ball rolling with the
crushing russian dude
is that just me
yeah she's my favorite character she's
real
difficult to learn yeah she's a blend of
a lot of different roles she can she's
like a support role kind of by
projecting shields on other people and
herself but then you have to consider
the fact that you're mainly doing that
not just to shield people because
they're pretty quick they dissipate
after like only a few seconds but that's
mainly to buff her tesla cannons damage
which that itself is also super
different in how you can use it because
it's a close range like just
concentrated laser which if you and
someone next to you are both taking
damage with shields that thing's gonna
be pretty powerful right but it's also a
grenade launcher that has a little it's
more less of an arc than like junkrat's
grenade launcher not as powerful as
junkrat's grenade launcher or
it's about as powerful but it's doesn't
not as high fire rate so then you have
that to consider but then you also have
her graviton surge which is probably my
favorite alt because right it's
devastating if you can pull it off it's
not good by itself i mean it can be if
there's like two people and you start
grenade launching if they don't know
what's going on because they're they're
not defenseless they can still shoot you
right and do most some of their
abilities but most of the time i find
they just freak out yeah yeah they just
start going like everyone it's okay you
can still do stuff but like if like i
said if you use hanzo's all to just
shoot the arrow straight into them both
dragons tear them apart if like farah's
just normal rocket launcher against them
is great junkrat just launching the
grenades into it uh it's
she's such a weird blend of these
different roles that i every time i play
i think about her in these different
layers especially like when you consider
the map and how your team composition
and their your opponent's composition
factors into it i don't know i play her
differently every time and it's it's
really fun that's awesome tell you what
about yourself who do you warm to on the
battlefield of overwatch gotta go may
all day payday may all day she's she's a
fun one um she does so many things
and i just gravitate to characters that
can kind of support and heal themselves
as well so like you don't always have to
depend on the healer so she can ice
block she doesn't take damage she heals
herself on top of that you can
technically use that to block off shots
like if there's a high noon if you want
to get really fancy he's like all right
ice block hide behind me because you
can't high noon you yeah so that's
awesome and then you got the
the wall she can make to you know either
kind of move around to higher grounds or
just to kind of mess with the other team
you wall them off you block them off
i've blocked like a junk rat tire before
i've blocked the diva charging in before
it's just like nah you're not going to
buy that
or you know like if you get shutting it
down yeah exactly or you know you can
really use it to split a team you know
sometimes just like get the hell like
trap them you know like
and both of her you know her primary uh
ability on her gun and her secondary
ability on her gun are both amazing you
know the first one's just kind of like a
you know like a little blow dryer type
effect but with ice it's like all right
you're frozen now i get to just right
click icicle you in the head and you're
probably surprisingly
powerful yeah like you can destroy a
reinhardt pretty good with that it's so
annoying to play against that too it's
so frustrating because the minute she
starts doing it you're just like running
away i hate when people play maywell
against me it's the most infuriating
thing yeah and yeah and then her like
icicle is like good to finish people off
that you freeze because like easy
headshot or it's good for like mid-ish
like almost semi-long range like i've
tried to out snipe a widowmaker even
though it's like not a good idea but
it's kind of fun to try yeah and uh her
alts another like kind of like fun wombo
combo type thing where it's really good
for
you know stopping uh payloads or like
you know like really controlling a
capture point because when you throw it
it's like that whole like radius is
going to be frozen yeah you don't want
to be in that so then it's like well
they're not going to come here or if
they shoot
your whole team gets to just it's free
pickings at that point they're all
frozen like great you combo that with
the wall in some interesting situations
as well just to block their exit and
then dump it on them in the middle um
speaking of widowmakers
and i love widowmaker so much like i'm
such a huge team for like if you were
you know they gave you the stats of like
how long you played each character in
team fortress 2 my sniper is just like
all the way up here and what i loved
about him with overwatch is that that
sniper had two different uh weapons he
had the straight up like sniper rifle
but he also had the crossbow which is
basically what hanzo is so hanzo's good
fun as well but man widowmaker's just
like so much fun because
i just think there's something about it
because
because there's always these big fracas
and because there's these long lanes and
you're essentially watching a lot of
people um
having fights pretty far away you can
like
just dispense so much sadness on an
opposition team by having a good
widowmaker by just like getting
headshots by taking out turrets but like
having them constantly worried where
they are like all the time especially if
their other team doesn't have a sniper
who's either you know cleaning up the
your widowmaker or
giving them like the sort of infrared
sight i just she's just so powerful if
you can pull it off right you can get
into interesting positions the
grappling hook allows you to like bail
out of places real quick if you need to
you can change where you are all the
time the ability to like charge up the
shot i mean charging up the shot and
getting a head shot like on it's just
like the most satisfying thing ever and
then just even just popping away people
when you've got like 50 charge just to
knock their health down she's just like
part of me feels like in the in the
right hands a widow maker can win a game
like oh yeah just destroy people um like
we had some interesting games last night
where i felt like i was like doing some
good widow-making yeah it was like one
game where i was 86 percent of the game
on fire or something and it was only
because these folks didn't know what to
do right and the only counter i feel
that's really good against there is
either a really good pharah who's able
to flank and dump down some shots or an
opposition widowmaker and then it
becomes like counter-strike because
you're like having this headshot hunch
right where you're like i need to get
the headshot cause i'm not you're gonna
get it
uh yeah i just i think she's absolutely
fantastic i've been switching to reaper
to counter her lately all right and i'm
not the best reaper player tay i think
you're the more experienced reaper
player um but yeah just warping up next
to her is the most satisfying thing and
if you do it right she's not going to
see like you come from like behind cover
right next to her and you are with the
shotgun's point at her head right there
yeah that's like figuring out the
counters in this game is so fun too
because like pharah is tough yeah really
tough you need some skill to take down
pharah in the air for most characters
but yeah i don't know like mccree is
another character he's probably my
second second favorite mane yeah what do
you like about him he's just a dirty
player and i love that like he once you
figure out the loop between not that
it's the same loop every time because i
think it that almost falls into a trap
of being okay flashbang fan the hammer
dodge automatic reload fan the hammer
yeah maybe die uh or walk away but if
you do it right you know when to just
use the primary single shot which is
really precise and i think they nerfed
it since the first early access because
it was pretty
uh the single shot yeah yeah it was like
two people i think the range got a
little nervous because it was like that
like straight beagle counters oh yeah
totally i mean like when we were talking
to jeff kaplan about it he said that at
one stage he was that mccree was able to
he was basically long range mid-range on
short range yeah and it's funny you say
counter-strike deagle because the
uh the gun is actually modeled after the
cult and half-life one oh do you
remember that do you remember that
desert like cult whatever called python
i think it was um cobra no python yeah
yeah exactly it's and it has that same
kickback as well which is such a great
feeling you're like playing 1998
half-life yeah blowing people up with
this thing that's the best thing and
well also you have his uh
dead eye which rice
i showed you the highlight this morning
i was pretty proud of it uh what map was
that was it dorado maybe or it was the
neutral control point mode but uh
i walked up the stairs and usually you
want to start deadeye from pretty far
away because you're vulnerable as hell
he doesn't have much health to begin
with and he's moved slowly but if you
time deadeye right and you come around
the corner and i saw three people locked
on because you're that was pretty close
killed those three came around the
corner soldier 76 came out like a trill
zone over time flashbang him fanned the
hammer we like pretty much won like
that's that kind of loop with him that i
love but he's still
he's still you have to be
practice with him right because he's
really vulnerable and you need to know
the timing and when to use primary when
to fan the hammer because if you don't
have that dodge roll ready the reload's
like the you know that reloading the six
snapping the chamber back in yeah he
just feels awesome and that's the same
reason i love pharah because it's a
similar kind of thing where you can very
easily get killed very quickly with her
if you don't protect yourselves from
like turrets and widowmakers but apart
from that if you can like get a handle
on them and you know
where not to jump in the air like super
early you can just like rain death on
people all the time it's like getting
above groups of people when they're
fighting each other and just landing
rockets down like flanking widowmakers
and taking them out taking out turrets
from miles away because your rockets are
so powerful and they're so far away that
you can just like i don't know it's
she's able to control long-range people
and then also like my favorite part in
this map we're showing now when you can
get inside of that area or inside of any
of these areas and fly up into the air
inside of the
control point and just kill people you
just you're just jumping up hovering
hovering hovering and then jumping up
hovering and just rockets and rockets
and rockets and like people don't have
an answer for it i mean the only answer
is either a decent sniper or a turrish
so it's so much fun what about you it is
a thing of beauty i watched you playing
this morning i was like oh okay i got to
steal some of these maneuvers because
like you know you can rock and jump and
hover but like i watch you play and it's
like oh this is like a whole different
animal but
um i'm gonna name a character that i
didn't think i would like okay but then
i think i'm starting to like and i was
even more jealous today when you got the
the the i think it was like the ifrit
uh
skin because
yeah i got that at the end of beta and i
was like oh i got to play them now that
i have that skin right like and i think
that's part of the the the hook of the
skins is it like you get another
character it kind of makes you want to
play that character you're like oh that
looks really cool i should try it and
you wouldn't think to play it anyways um
i didn't think i like him he's he's
pretty low health he's like 75 health
and like 75 shield yeah but his discord
orb which is basically a debuff on the
on the uh opposing enemies like it just
makes them like
nothing it's like oh you're a reinhardt
not really not anymore armor right yeah
it's armor um
but
he's he
he's deceptively strong i think like
offensively too because he can like his
orbs can go pretty far i like outsniped
the widowmaker i'm guessing she was bad
but like with zenyatta i mean we had a
run on the livestream earlier today
where chris played zenyatta and you were
playing with him actually you were
reinhardt
and he just destroyed everyone i've
never seen anything like i didn't
realize that this guy was so he's the
most like offensive support actor by a
mile he was destroying everyone he was
debuffing everyone and then just like
pounding those balls yeah and i didn't
realize yeah the distance yeah pound
those balls man i didn't realize the
distance you get on those things like he
yeah no
he can get it's like pretty long range
yeah and so like he's pretty vulnerable
when you get up close to him but his
best like kind of maneuver is his right
click he basically charges like five
yeah and then he just lets it all rip so
you can like take out turrets with that
and everything yeah so you just like
kind of queue it up especially like if a
widowmaker has got the the infrared you
kind of queue it up before you round the
corner yeah yeah surprise totally yeah
because she hasn't got that much else
either yeah and it's all it's just
amazing because like you have to respect
it like when he's ulting it's like okay
i guess the whole team's just gonna get
healed for like a lot and they're gonna
have this control point and i don't we
don't know what to do i think chris had
the best like scenario where it's like
the reinhardt just kind of like pins him
away but like you don't take damage but
like that takes the heel away from the
rest of it but that's that's the only
other thing i could think is is a
concussion blast with pharah it's just
yeah but then there's like lucio coming
in right yeah yeah something lisa is
great yeah yeah cause lucio if he's
healing everybody he uh or well not when
he drops the beat but when he does the
uh
let's raise the roof oh yeah or yeah
whatever it's called he he's vulnerable
you can still kill him while he's doing
that same with mercy you can kill her
whenever right uh he you just have to
say [ __ ] they're going to be healed yeah
you have to do something
yeah there you go overwatch that's some
of our favorite characters let us know
what yours are in the comments below um
i mean that's the most exciting thing
about this game is that like
everyone's got a different one and it's
not just based on some you know stupid
aesthetic thing or
we're not like forcing it it's like it's
a genuinely just these these characters
are just so well created like both in
terms of how they look but also it's
just gameplay-wise so unique like each
of us here and most people playing the
game probably look at overwatch
completely differently people totally
different favorite characters like the
game looks so much different as a from a
widowmaker's perspective than it does
from a winston that's why i play pharah
in widowmaker i'm basically playing team
fortress i'm a soldier or the sniper
like right i'm playing the same people
i've ever always played in video games
i'm playing quake and i'm playing
counter-strike like
it's it's crazy i think two the reason
why it's kind of like
you have memories too i think like there
are like not even just play of the games
but you have all these memorable
scenarios of like okay you're gonna
remember that high noon you did right
like for a while now and i think as long
as it keeps creating these memories it
makes it like even a more long lasting
game because
you always like those are things you
want to talk about like oh yeah it was
man i did this you know and and that's
kind of like what makes this game fun
it's like every day something different
can happen but you'll remember that and
it'll be like oh that was awesome yeah
crazy stuff it's interesting it's
interesting talking about it today and
it has been interesting seeing like
public reaction unfold over the past
couple of weeks with the with the beta
as well the open beta and it's going to
be very interesting to look in six
months time especially when we're
looking at game of the year stuff to see
where this lands as well because
god damn it it's been a good year 2016.
yeah i mean we're talking about
gamespot's 20th you know anniversary and
we've got videos and articles going up
on the side all week about that
like
we're doing all right like yeah we
thought 2015 was 2015. that was already
that was like a new 2004. that was like
picking a game of year last night year
was a nightmare between metal gear solid
and bloodborne and rocket league in the
witcher i mean this year we've already
had like uncharted overwatch [ __ ]
doom man yeah how good was doom they
made a good doom game i know like what's
going on have we all died is this like
the afterlife they made a good doom game
eid of all people made a good doom game
yeah they haven't made a good game in a
while i've played like four games this
year where i'm like this might be my
game of the year yeah and every time
it's something else replaces it what
else are you thinking is there any other
uh for me the ones up there dark souls
three x-core
yeah the witness the witness which is
such an extremely different beast and
all these ones we're talking about well
i guess they're all different in their
own way but yeah this game's been this
year's been far cry primal was good fun
the definition of surprise the defense
you should shut up
i mean why uh yeah like there have been
some i mean i feel like quantum break
was some people enjoyed it i wasn't
massive
at battleborn as well um i feel for
those guys a bit they dropped the price
into 40 yesterday hopefully to maybe get
a couple more sales um on the other side
of that but uh yeah i mean we've still
got the last guardian no man's sky
there's a gears of war coming out this
year battle council dishonored two
battlefield one yeah what'd you say
mankind divided of course yeah god um
maybe infinite warfare will blow all her
faces off could you imagine i hope it
does i really hope it does i'm not yeah
i'm not i'm skeptical but i hope it is
skeptical but hopeful maybe it'll work
out it's that like kind of you don't
have any expectations you're like ah
it's probably going to be all right
maybe not so great oh wow my warfare is
coming back yeah
that's what i'm excited part of the
bundle
it's only part of the bundle though it's
not separate at least not yet you know
why he's part of the bundle to sell
infinite warfare are you buying that
game otherwise you don't think so maybe
maybe i'm hoping for it i'm hoping for
boating i think we're getting two
interesting military shooters with e3
rather but the expectation bar is low
you gotta say that sorry civilization
six god the amount of strategy games are
coming out this year as well civ 6
preview going up tomorrow i played 60
turns of it
was that 400 hours no that's like
it's like an hour okay that's not that
long for like step five that could be
like half an hour the more you play it
but six was a little
different discussion but there's a lot
new with it you should check that out if
you like civilization games or strategy
games is mafia 3 coming out this year
yeah i think so i'm excited for that
yeah man video game is doing all right
as it turns out
let's have a break for a couple of weeks
before e3 how about that yeah 19 days
until the big electronic triple
overwatch rocket league for the next two
weeks yeah exactly watching rocket
league for the next little while uh
thank you so much for uh hanging out
today really appreciate it everyone in
the back jean-luc psyche miss mary kish
who else is back there just them because
you're right here today eric taylor
oh kvo of course
go hang out with him before he shoots
off to belgium richard lee of course on
the camera right there uh thanks forever
they go hey look it's kevin hanging out
kevin we're still not paying you
still not paying attention nothing nope
nada we're not paying you we're going to
give him euros now that's what he gets
euros aren't the euros more strong
though more strong
eric
economic analysis analysis analyst
got him damn it you can't make a joke
and then screw it up
all right we're done thank you so much
everyone for hanging out in the twitch
chat really appreciate it uh thank you
so much for listening to this on your
ipad ipad
the three of you listening to this on
your ipad thank you so much
yeah okay we're gone thank you adios
bye-bye see you next week tuesday
overwatch review coming soon bye
you